[Music]
mr. Shapiro
good morning good sir good morning how
are you doing well
before I get to obviously you have some
general info we'll have all the info
what was uh what was it what would the
show like what would you say the vibe
was like here compared to Berkeley well
I mean that I think there was less fear
among the students but people were
pumped in the room mhmmm at Berkeley
because there was such a build-up there
was there was a lot of fear that you
know there's gonna be violence and I
think there was there was fear that
there's gonna be violence outside for
sure but you guys obviously got the
brunt of it I think you may have
inoculated and I actually it sounds like
but it's you know people people were in
through these people were pumped up that
the the event was take Jesus he's
holding a hand held to just hold it like
a fake tripod get moving get the MTV
camera going you know what that's the
whole purpose is to move that's don't
just have the same shot of McKenzie that
you're ripping on the hero of our story
here well he's still an employee mr. uh
so it was funny we were all kind of
surprised with the Utah yeah visit that
was the thing like a woman when I was
hearing from you what was going on kind
of behind the scenes you know I was
thinking like if I die in Utah that's
gonna be weird like if I get stabbed to
death in Utah
like really Utah and what if he happens
to be a Mormon then you can never well
then you know I've made that made this
joke on Twitter so many times whenever
there's an Islamic terror attack I tweet
something like the damn Mormons and if I
actually was stabbed to death in Utah
that would be somewhat ironic actually
was at one time in Utah you'd have to be
like okay hold on there's an asterisk
here yes but I mean and as I opened the
speech saying this is the only state in
the Union where where I speak here and
I'm the least clean-cut person in the
room there very well did it make you
nervous because it looks like they're
straight from a page of Hitler Youth
hear it all tall and blond handsome
people cuz the Mormons clean-living
that's just the reality I was in Provo
one time and I remember she's gonna like
this looks like an Abercrombie
convention this is really funny so this
is the folks at ABC News they're asking
me like did it make you uncomfortable
you know saying all the things that you
say in front of this largely white
audience and I was like no
I think I say this in front of largely
not white audiences also but that's the
way a lot of these folks think
unfortunately do they look out and it's
like they just see a color palette yeah
and what's crazy is with anta fatu i we
kind of realized this here I'll let you
read through these this is their cryptic
app and their text so you can read
through but I'll just tell you we
realized yet will we know everything
about will by the way if everything
about them this Firebird Xevious will
like we'll just put some effort into
this yeah your your code name will be
Bob yes your code name will be steven
crowder I wonder and then and then you
wonder how that Garrett was able to
infiltrate my geniuses how is he able to
do this and not a single news agency
this is a great question not one and not
one when we showed them the footage the
cops were there they said hey we're
working what do you mean you're working
on News yeah I'm also whoever has my
knife don't lose that what in the war
call the cops spectacular yeah that's
like what is this steven crowder we're
gonna I don't know I don't want to get
doxed by oh my gosh that's amazing no
but it is it you guys did more
undercover journalistic work than than
any of these any of these major outlets
I mean like they've been writing about
and Tifa from this 30,000 foot view like
who are these people it's a big mystery
you guys just kind of walk in the front
door and you think we thought okay
really just using this as an excuse you
know for violence or I think
unfortunately oh and it brings all
different kinds of people
they're so delusional they think they're
out there genuinely oppressed and
they're out there fighting like Nazis
and they think you're a white sir I was
wondering about like do they even know
who I am because my theory was that they
have no clue who I am and that they're
just finding whoever is the most
prominent right-wing speaker on campus
to make trouble for no they genuinely I
don't know so much about you
specifically but they genuinely believe
that conservatives basically anyone who
disagrees with them is a white
supremacist yeah yeah exactly that's
sort of what I figured because I'm not
arrogant enough to think these people
are like online watching
like videos you know like no but I
thought maybe they just said it as like
hey if we label them a white supremacist
I thought there was a possibility label
them in Nazi kind of like the left
proactive we just had racist even if
they don't really believe it I think the
difference is here with these activists
they actually they're diluted enough
they believe it that's yeah that's
that's a little scary
it's scary because I think I think if
you see this little people are scary
people I mean when they when they have
knives and such I mean that's that
that's when it starts getting shot off
shotguns which probably are not legal
anywhere that's that's it that's wild
they smile we were like conceal carry
unless he's less he's shoving it down
like a pirate walking with a peg leg
even then it's not legal to sawfish shot
yeah yeah so I mean do you see this
getting more violent do you see that
erupting coming to a head a work that's
generally our concern
yeah I think that you are gonna see some
sort of incident where it where it gets
violent at you know a speech like mine
just because they're showing up we've
seen NTV get violent before obviously
there was basically a red on Brown beat
down in Sacramento like August 2016 yeah
right so that's it so that I wouldn't
that I wouldn't be shocked by but I mean
you have this many unstable people
looking to carry around weapons
apparently at places like this I think
it's only a matter of time before
somebody goes off and hurt somebody and
then the question is gonna be does the
media cover in the same way that they
covered Charlottesville you know when
anything actually killed somebody we're
gonna cover it like okay is this a
mainstream problem on the left has the
left done too much to to embolden this
movement I think it would take killing
because they're pepper spraying they've
lacked people with with weapons they've
knocked people out with bike locks we
have all this you know on camera exactly
in the media doesn't care well they
believe maybe their tactics aren't know
their tactics are they're they're
handing out ice picks and talking about
sawed-off shotguns and luring people
back to the car so that's a part you're
telling me about that I like today
they're giving their getting that gauge
here at the knife and then the ice pick
and then it's like they're they keep
going back to the car and bring it's
like it's like a Tom and Jerry cartoon
and they go back to the car they become
a stick of dynamite they bring him the
little bomb with the actual flaming wick
right on the end it's like a it's like a
clown with a handkerchief of armaments
Mary Poppins I don't in and you know no
one no one was interested when they say
hey we're working kid I'm like well you
work on news right and this is this
seems more newsworthy than just a bunch
of people standing around chanting
one of my speeches that was their news
if you had a loser's like um and talking
about controversial speaker but I'm
gonna second
they don't call been a controversial
speaker they call him and not that's
exactly right they don't they don't say
hey we're protesting they spray paint
they chalk punch a Nazi and you can hear
them saying you're a Nazi
none of that ever gets mentioned I do
love the tape of the woman saying the
most dangerous person in America it's
like we have you you have them on tape
handing out knives and I'm the most
dangerous at America like really I can
barely use a butter knife legless but I
came in butter mahalo like what are you
even talking about here it is it is
fully crazy yeah even with them you know
the right way but this is racist like
he's the most dangerous person America
really you think he's more dangerous
than I don't know Mike Brown Tookie
Williams how about the leaders of the
Bloods and the Crips there are a lot of
dangerous people in this country I don't
think I rank in the top three well maybe
I'm number four say ed you live the
pictures they put on the posters of me
where they find the most nasty looking
photo of me then they darken it yeah
I've got the evil like hit Larry and
eyebrows yeah pretty pretty spectacular
I'm gonna have to put that in a big
poster in our office and then then they
do is side by side of the dsm-5 and mine
come like when you talk about it is a it
is a gender dysphoria yeah how it's
classified as a disorder right
no no surprise I see a shrink I read
these manuals he actually said it's DSM
right do some yeah so do some more yeah
and do some three is more actually
that's right they just got a cure it's
got more politicized overtime and you
can see how it's changed over time but
it is yeah it's it's incredible that
these people find this stuff so Nazi yes
that they feel like they need to show up
with nice it was funny again some of
these members of the media who don't
necessarily know anything about me
because they don't watch any of my stuff
or godlike you or they don't like me
they but some of them last night went to
the speech and they walked out and and I
talked to them afterward they're like
wait they were purchasing that like
really that's what they were that's what
they were going crazy over yeah and
that's that's what's so shocking about
this to people I think is that it
doesn't take somebody being a
provocateur saying crazy stuff in order
for these people to go off they'll go
off basically if you sneeze I know well
you know that's why I stopped doing
after UMass cuz yeah people people don't
realize that video I had come walk tout
I plan to do a 15-minute set yeah and
when you have truly puffs you know she
doesn't have enough middle
fingers to give I have never done that
on show on stage and we're running very
little sleep in case you can't tell um
and I just I don't wanna do this anymore
because I you know my goal is not to be
a provocateur on campus my goal is to do
stand-up but now it's almost to the
point where you know it's just a part of
the program yep we've talked about maybe
getting back in the road maybe doing
some some college shows it'll just have
to be different because you can't just
do stand-up they're gonna protest so
we'll have to know that they're there
and address them QA and change the way
we I mean I think I think she do your
live podcast there I think she'd do they
shouldn't use a full live podcast in
front of an audience and they'll be
awesome that would be fun
you can you imagine that just the
monologue that just the jokes in the
first 10 minutes how many help how
pissed they would be amazing it'd be
amazing just we would just let it ride
the MS man who called himself MC
bulletproof was shot dead today and
before we even get to the punchline they
would be shrieking everything but what I
think is amazing about what you guys did
here is that again you committed an act
of journalism and that seems more and
more uncommon I remember I was doing
interview with somebody from I think
it's Columbia Journalism Review recently
and they're talking about you know what
makes a journalist and I said we need to
stop using the term journalist and you
need to start talking about who is
actually committing acts of journalism
right because not an act of journalism
for you to sit in your office in New
York and write your perspective on an
Tifa and having never done any of the
actual groundwork right you guys what
what you did you know some of the stuff
James O'Keefe does for example these are
acts of journalism and it doesn't matter
that you have a perspective journalism
is journalism and you did something that
they weren't willing to do well I'd like
to think it's some of the Andrew not the
name nothing
not the trademark the name what yeah
what like Santa and it would have been
so into this I just you know it's like
the only who'd be I feel like you'd be
really at his best in this in this
environment I think so yeah particulars
antiphon black lives matter I mean I
wouldn't have be surprised if he tried
to get to this first but we were
surprised
like we said we and one thing to I
because Ben was sort of like the flood
the flycatcher you know is that that
glow light and well we know we know
they're gonna be there for Ben but I let
you know everything was on the up and up
again we're doing this just so you know
Oh handing out axe picks
keep your head in a swivel exactly
just been need to have a Kevlar now he's
fine we're gone now yes
yeah you guys yeah I wish I had you guys
always in my advanced team we can send
not Garrett into all of these places
yeah I mean having him infiltrate BLM
might be a little tough but it's but no
really be tough it all out next
assignment is what you do you slap a
pair of tits on him you call him an ally
they won't say anything they're
terrified they don't question they will
not question anyone who's got a gender
identity disorder never I still don't
know who Firebird was it a male to
female we don't know we still don't know
well the mystery abides I Ben Shapiro
the Ben Shapiro show daily wire.com
terrible tumbler good show and I'm glad
you're safe where's your next lab
performance so we are doing University
of Tennessee at the end of the month so
that should be another party of merrily
see how that goes hey if you liked this
video subscribe by clicking the button
that says subscribe if you didn't like
this video you should subscribe anyway
because then you can watch the next
video and what you can do is down vote
it and leave a comment that's really
negative you know particularly if it's
something like I don't know maybe anti
somatic even though I'm not Jewish or
something about my hair or something
about my weird nose just leave a really
negative comments that everyone else
around can act like they care